الاطفال وبقدر ما كانوا الاوفر حظا
بالنجاه من تحت انقاذ الزلزال المدمر
بتركيا اصبحوا اليوم الفئه الاكثر تضررا
من صدمه الكارثه اثار الصدمه علقت في
اذهانهم فصارت مضمونه لرسومات تخطها
اناملهم
بسبب وفاه ابنه عمي في الزلزال ويضم صرع
قلت نائمه حين حدوث الزلزال فايقظتني امي
كان زلزال مروعا وعند هروب مع ابي وامي
انهارت بنا سلالم البيت
ونحن هنا نهتم بالاطفال كما تعلمون فان
مساحات اللعب المخصصه لهم قد دمرت واللعب
بالقرب منها خطير هنا يلعبون ويرسمون
ويعبرون عن مشاعرهم فالرسم من افضل الطرق
للتعبير عن المشاعر ومحاوله نسيان ما
شاهدوه من صور الدمار والماسي
لوحات بريئه قد لا تصمد طويلا على سياج
هذه الساحه في هاتاي لكن المشرفين على
مبادره ياملون في ان تساعد الاطفال على
نسيان جراح الزلزال المدمر العالقه في
ذاكرتهم
نحاول ازاله اثار معاشه الاطفال من
الزلزال عبر هذه المساحه التي تحتوي على
العاب وكتب للمطالعه والرسم ونؤمن لهم
الطعام كذلك وكما تعلمون المدارس مغلقه في
الولايات المتضرره والاطفال يحتاجون الى
الرعايه والتعليم
تشير التقديرات الاوليه الى تضرر اكثر من
مليوني طفل من الزلزال في تركيا فيما تحذر
منظمه اليونيسيف الامميه من تبعات ذلك
عليهم مثل هذه الفضاءات المخصصه للاطفال
وفي هذا التوقيت بالذات ستجنب لا محاله
مالات غير محموده لهذه الفئه التي عاشت
هول كارثه الزلزال المدمر دعم نفسي
ومرافقه بمختلف الانشطه قد تعيد لهم واجهه
الحياه من جديد عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
هاتاي جنوب تركيا